crazy story coming out of the Washington
Post Pentagon opens sweeping review of
clandestine psychological operations
complaints about the U.S military's
influence operations using Facebook and
Twitter have raised concerns in the
White House and federal agencies
how about that what Luke yeah how about
that right I I saw the story story I did
a report on it earlier today and
Facebook and Twitter surprisingly also
took action on this and removed accounts
that were running what what is being
described here by even the Pentagon U.S
psychological operations that were being
run on the American people these were
clandestine psyopses that were of course
pushing a narrative pushing an agenda
using your tax dollars to open up social
media accounts in order to brainwash the
American public this was an extremely
dangerous story let me read this the
researchers does not did not specify
when the takedowns occurred but those
familiar with the matter said they were
within the past two or three years some
were recent and involved posts from the
summer that advanced anti-russian
narratives citing the kremlin's
imperialist war in Ukraine and warning
of the conflicts direct impact on
Central Asian countries significantly
they found that the pretend personas
employing tactics used by countries such
as Russia and China did not gain much
traction and that overt accounts
actually attracted more followers
so what do you see when you go on Reddit
it is laughable I'm sorry there are
people who fall for this but here's the
Sorting algorithm of the left and the
right in the culture War when you go on
Reddit and you see a video of a
Ukrainian guy and he's like smoking a
cigar and he's laughing and he's like
this is what I think of Russia haha and
they flip the cigarette they all high
five each other like that's propaganda
you have cyber command you have
psychological operations you have them
producing this content
faking it so that they can put it out
there and convince you that we're better
we're stronger we're going to win this
war
now I don't I don't have a an issue with
it to a certain degree but it is
extremely annoying often when you know
these videos are outright propaganda and
then what happens now we're seeing
Vladimir Putin reigning these these uh
incendiary devices all over cities
threatening to mass mobilize the
entirety of Russia and that there's fear
he could potentially open a second front
maybe Finland we don't know but all the
propagandists in the military keep doing
it saying Ukraine's winning Russia's
losing Rush can't win and then Russia
doesn't isn't even using their their
pinky in this conflict to be fair
they're getting pushed back Ukrainian
forces with NATO's assistants are
advancing all that's true but what they
want you to do they want you to believe
that Russia could never win for morale
reasons they want people to put the
Ukrainian Flags we we drive down here in
Virginia there's a little small town you
gotta drive through when you're passing
through and they have big we stand with
Ukraine and I'm like the point to where
Ukraine was on a map right it is it is
psychological operations to convince the
American people to support Mass spending
of War yeah all of this as of course
Western politicians like Boris Johnson
are on record telling zelinski not to
come to negotiations not to offer peace
not to try to stop the conflict this was
another bombshell story that that I
think is definitely worth talking about
is the Western governments telling
Ukraine hey no peace deal no
negotiations here continue the war this
is Perpetual award that I call that from
the very beginning CNN was telling you
it was only going to last a few days I
was telling you hey it's probably going
to last a few years might even last 10
years might even last forever with the
way that of course the
military-industrial complex is shaping
itself in the way that they've been
funding themselves and the way that the
stocks have been of course increasing
but but again these psyop Pages here are
are worth noting because the Pentagon is
going to be ordering an audit on the dod
for these psychological operations that
are played out on the American people
and this is what we know about what
don't we know about what else is
happening behind the scenes when it
comes to psyopsis since of course all
again information has been weaponized
and it has been weaponized against the
best interest of the American people one
thing is talking plasma where they fire
lasers into the sky and coordinate a
bunch of different lasers to get a ball
of plasma and then they move it around
and say it's a UAP unidentified aerial
phenomenon and they're freaking people
out making them think that there might
be aliens well this is this is what they
did in Vietnam short-lived they played
audio recordings of people wailing
saying I should I'm trapped here forever
run run home to your kids don't be like
me and it freaked even the South Korea
I'm sorry the South Vietnamese out so I
think they're doing I want to mention
comments on videos too so when you check
your feed and you're like this is the
response okay that this is the thoughts
of the day that's psyopsis that's I
think I think Reddit was taken over a
long time ago Twitter I'm sure YouTube
is they can't control it people are
coming from outside and using the
platform this is why Twitter they're
trying to implement algorithmic feeds
because then they can justify
controlling people which is a point you
often make about knowing the the code to
prevent this kind of thing because if
you don't know what the code's doing you
don't know how Facebook Twitter and
Reddit are manipulating you to to twist
your thoughts to make you compliant but
I'll tell you one thing there's a story
I read recently I know you guys probably
heard about Mass graves in Ukraine you
guys hear the story no no actually you
hear this I heard a lot of different
stories about Mass graves in Europe so
so you've got you've got two factions in
a war obviously we as Americans are
expected to support Ukraine because NATO
and all that stuff but there's two
stories the story from the West is that
the Russians created Mass Graves the
story from Russia and Eastern sources is
that Russia told Ukraine to collect
their debt and Ukraine refused so the
Russians gave them proper burials choose
who you believe I I don't I don't
believe Russia's narratives it's the
same BS they're military their
psychological operations are going to be
are going to be coming at us the exact
same as the U.S will is a battle for
your mind it is fifth generational War
absolutely and the first casualty of war
is truth and I I think you can't believe
anyone because everyone has an invested
interest in using information for their
own personal benefit but at the end of
the day we have seen a concerted effort
to push for a Perpetual proxy war that
there is no end to that endangers all of
Europe that is creating an energy crisis
that is creating a scarcity problem
problem that is creating a food famine
problem for a lot of the people in the
world who are the poorest people in the
world and and this is something that is
absolutely mind-boggling because even
coming to the table and saying hey there
should be negotiations there should be
peace deals we should be incentivizing
the end of this conflict in some shape
form or way where we could actually come
to the table and actually negotiate a
stop to this utter Madness because
politicians sending people to die for
their political Ambitions is one of the
stupidest idea in recorded human history
and it needs to end and it needs to stop
and it stops when the people stop
complying and I think this is an
important message that I think a lot of
people need to hear and sadly you don't
hear it on Reddit you don't hear it on
social media you don't you don't hear it
on the corporate media you don't hear it
by government officials you hear the
opposite of that and this is why this
conflict is going to continue but
they're losing I I think information War
you mean but Annie Leibovitz got a very
beautiful photo shoot yeah tell me about
that it's a joke Vogue did a whole
spread on uh on the first lady of
Ukraine yeah yeah in in the war-torn
country she's like sporting beautiful
pea coats it's it's pretty toned up I
don't know if it's true but I heard that
zielinski was wearing these nice these
like Nikes did you guys see that um like
really nice shoes I mean he's a lot to
have nice shoes it's fine whatever he's
very but but I think I think we're
winning and I think back to uh the bush
years didn't the Dixie Chicks they like
criticized Bush and then they got they
got canceled or whatever yeah everyone's
like you gotta support the troops yeah
nowadays
it's creepy how the institutions and the
establishment are waving Ukrainian flags
and just you know
just well we'll keep a family friend I
was gonna say something you know uncouth
but uh you know just just uh abiding by
the cult narrative and support of the
war but uh shows like this can exist
where we just say screw your war and
screw you and that that's that's
something you know that's powerful it's
at least you know a message out there
but still tragically so many people are
losing their lives in Ukraine so many
young people are just having their
entire existences wiped out because
politicians have Ambitions and that to
me is just such a crazy idea a
politician saying hey go kill your
fellow neighbor right now because I said
so it's wild that this has happened
throughout recorded human history and it
needs it needs to stop a lot of it is
like utilitarian they're saying okay if
we don't invade the Middle East uh
Afghanistan for that oil we're gonna
lose 100 million Americans are going to
die from starvation in the next 50 years
so are we willing to sacrifice two
million people to make sure that the 50
million don't die and that's the
strategy and the planning of resource
management I mean war is Resource
Management it's Land Management and and
resources
um and it's not just that it's them
saying if we don't go in the Middle East
China will
that's also you take that into account
like if we don't invade someone will
which is it's not just that simple the
U.S involvement in the Middle East
propped up Iran Iran is as powerful it
has more of a sphere of influence
because of the war in Iraq the war in
Iraq created Isis created radical
sectarian violence if you look at it
it's not as simple exactly they want the
chaos they want the murder they want the
destruction they don't want the war on
terror to end they want it to continue
and they made sure it continued by
radicalizing groups and also pushing
people out of the government in Iraq
which literally created Isis who is that
guy who was in Congress who was right
about everything
um his name was Dr Ron Paul
there's a viral video of him going
around recently that it's actually gone
viral several times where he's just
calmly explaining what is happening and
what will happen based on the things
we're doing and like it all happened
yeah blowback I think was his term in
like 2007 he was very very vocal CIA
yeah I have a t-shirt saying if I told
you so was a person with him smiling
thing on it uh but but he called it he
called it especially when it came to the
FBI the politicization of the FBI that
historically has been going on with them
abusing their power that they had in
Washington DC he talked about the
Patriot Act he talked about the war on
terror he talked about the war on drugs
and all of those roosters are coming
home to roost because he was right dead
on the money on so many issues and he it
was like he had a magic eight ball he
predicted all of it and it all came true
and if you would have listened the world
would have been a better place well I
think what we're seeing with the
anti-establishment wave was deeply
influenced by him and the Ron Paul
Revolution back in I think it was like
2008 the Tea Party Revolution which was
hijacked by Glenn Beck and other kind of
uh Stronger neoconservative
right-wingers but that was Ron Paul or
what Ron Paul originally uh was one of
the major figureheads behind the tea
party that was pro-freedom pro-free
Speech anti-war Pro uh America and then
a lot of other right-wing figures came
over and kind of hijacked it and it
became just the like a republican thing
and it became an establishment thing but
originally it was anti-establishment
anti-us Federal Reserve anti-imperialism
anti-uh you know globalist but I'll say
this you know when I was growing up in
the city uh everyone's very liberal we
all saw the viral Ron Paul Revolution we
saw the stickers everywhere and I
remember seeing it says like it says
like Revolution and love is backwards or
whatever and like Revolution the Ron
Paul Love Revolution what a funny that's
so weird I don't think he came up with
that some people just started doing it
right I think yeah it was viral
marketing because his ideas you know
spurred on so many people to take
independent actions there was people
that literally had uh you know air
balloons that that had huge you know
signs Billboards that were just put up
up without the campaign's coordination
and his message was able to get out
there because of Grassroots support he
also was supported by U.S military
service members more than any other
candidate in that specific election that
he was a part of and he galvanized a lot
of people to take independent action
without any top-down control which was
very impressive I just I think I think
uh Ron Paul's influence had a huge
impact on our generation because I mean
2008 was it was something it was for a
few years even after that people were
talking about his ideas and what he what
he what he believed and what he
represented and the things that he got
right even today and then there's a lot
of people now who have become they very
much were seated with these ideas of
libertarian values anti-establishment
Anti-Imperialist now there's many many
more people who share the views of Ron
Paul not to mention his kids actually in
government and carrying on what a
testament to his his personality that
his child is such an amazing human being
is really incredible and boy did does
the cult hate it but it's because of Ron
greatly not not completely that I think
we're sinks to strong Anti-Imperialist
anti-war anti-establishment
pro-individual Liberties Pro Freedom
Movement I think I think that what he
represented and stuck to rippled out
it's unfortunate that Bernie Sanders
ultimately caved to The Establishment in
the end because he could have he could
have stood for something on the left in
a similar way I get I got to talk to you
guys about it and he and he kissed the
ring and he bowed down and they screwed
him over and they slapped him around he
said please give me more and it was
disgusting to see exactly him him just
just just give up and and screw over all
of his followers he had Grassroots
support too he had individuals saying
hey I don't I don't need to be paid by
anyone I don't need to be organized by
anyone I stand for his ideas that
represent the middle class the blue
collar working class of this people and
then at the end of the day he pooped on
all of them let's just be real with
ourselves I'm trying to put my mind in
the state of someone in the government
in in control of the War Machine and why
they're doing it because I'm very
anti-war I'm very like yo get the troops
out of the Middle East we shouldn't be
invading people end of story killing is
wrong you know very kind of black and
white and then I start to think like
well wait if there's a military if there
are resource management issues and and
the American people really are running
out of resources or or projected to that
unless we invade and take them from
somewhere else
where does good and evil starts to lose
that's not true that's a notion that is
absolutely made up that is absolutely
ridiculous and has no sense at all
the Savage we're not taking the
resources and no one took the resources
in Afghanistan the Chinese are taking
the resources in Afghanistan after the
United States gave it to them on the
silver platter are we taking any
resources from Libya no we just brought
back slavery to that but like there's
there's no conquest of of resources the
British none of that there's British no
it's not as simple as you think it is I
think it might not be as simple but the
British took North America and took the
resources on the east coast of this
continent and then they murdered 90 of
the Native American population calling
them Savages didn't even consider them
human for the resources and now we have
one of the most Bountiful resource
country on the earth you're you're
technically wrong it was individuals
doing it all the crown I mean I was
reading I I was reading about the war
for independence recently and I was like
I wonder what the king what King George
was King George III I think said when he
received the Declaration of Independence
he ignored it he handed up some other
guy and said I don't know you deal with
it they didn't care the crown didn't
care he thought of the the colonies as a
nuisance what it was was individuals
trying to find a better life they were
leaving Europe the colonization was in
some ways you had elements of trade and
the crown was like there's riches to be
had but what people don't understand
about colonization is that it's best
represented by what we're seeing now
with China regular people in China moved
to other countries they said they they
said they create lives there they grow
they expand they create businesses they
gain influence that's colonization the
colonists from Europe came to the
Americas to find a better life it was
crowded a lot of them weren't succeeding
in Europe they said I'd be better off in
a new frontier and those individuals
created cities created colonies and had
conflict the natives and they favored
themselves over the natives who live
there
so it's not like the crown was just like
there's people there let's have all of
our people go and crush them by order of
the king yeah they just wanted the
resource of the tobacco and those
individuals the individual companies
individual people yeah but it was
resource greed I mean maybe not greed
maybe that's just the nature of humanity
as more resources more people and if you
don't get more resources then you're
gonna starve exactly you take two dogs
and you put them in a cage and you and
they're both hungry and you throw in one
chicken what's gonna happen are they
gonna share so now probably my thoughts
on Conquest is like is shaken I'm not so
like no more war never everyone be
peaceful now I just don't it seems too
Pie in the Sky it is I I I think um the
problem I have with the United States is
they've never Justified at least in my
lifetime any of their Wars they claim
they have justification but it's always
some weird bunk reason they keep lying
to us about so my attitude is you do not
get my consent in a government uh that
is granted that is supposed to have the
consent of the governed you don't have
my consent to lie to me to justify why I
should do work pay you taxes so you can
go blow up kids Barack Obama there's no
justification for that you want to prove
you had a reasonable doubt that someone
is worthy of death you have to prove it
and they've not done that so if they
were like just saying I think it's the
Petro dollar I think it's it's they want
a unipolar world because they don't want
to deal with competition they don't want
a World War it's the liberal
International International economy it's
it's this we're better off with the
power otherwise it would be worse and
that does not get Grant you the right to
execute people in other countries or or
for these people in the Middle East to
these little kids come out of their
houses and they see drones flying
overhead and they never know and that
drone is going to blow them up is a
psychotic way to force people to live
they do not have my consent for that
yeah if they were honest they wouldn't
have everyone Behind These larger ideas
than these larger conquests and these
larger acts of murder because if they
were honest they would be like hey we're
just trying to get some money here we're
a hammer everything's starting to look
like a nail we need to make some profit
here and Ian they're not going for
resources and bringing you back
resources they're not doing that they're
helping their friends in the military
industrial complex there's no bid
contracts there's there's the
weaponization of of the US military that
of course is in private hands that only
take care of those private hands and
even screw over the soldiers that
volunteer themselves because they think
they're fighting for freedom and
democracy they're not and you know why
you know why one of the reasons so many
people wanted Donald Trump just one of
the reasons is that whether or not you
actually care about those kids coming
out of their little houses and seeing
another drone flying overhead and
wondering when they'll blow up maybe
you're thinking like I don't know about
those kids I don't care I'll tell you
this that drone in the 50 million
dollars that equipped it could have gone
to your town to your schools to your
roads to your industry to your jobs and
instead it's being siphoned Away by a
bunch of morons who will want a nation
building Afghanistan screw the whole
thing up and then hand it over to China
money hungry murderers let's just be
real with ourselves maybe but they know
no bounds when it comes to destroying
and killing other people and and they'll
do it to the tune of hundreds of
thousands of millions yeah they have
done it before lateral damage why
because they don't want what resources
did you get from uh Syria what resources
did you get from understand what
resources did you get from Libya what
resources did you get from Somalia we
didn't know we didn't as far as I
learned in Iraq for instance there were
lots of oil we get oil from Saudi Arabia
and we still Finance their lethal uh
genocide of the people in Yemen which is
a proxy war so we're that's where we're
getting oil from Saudi Arabia from Iraq
like oil but if we ran out of oil here
people would start eating each other no
but under Donald Trump we were near
energy Independence and I know it was a
pandemic and demand was weighed down but
gas in some areas dropped below two
bucks but on average it dropped way down
and Donald Trump was moving us towards
energy Independence we are able to do it
now Joe Biden's doing the opposite he's
shutting down pipelines he's saying no
to fracking environmental's got a
problem with it but I'll tell you what
what the administration what the
Democrats with the unit party's done
they they don't like the pollution here
they Outsource it to China so what they
do is they say we're going to pass all
these environmental regulations so you
can't do anything dirty here how do you
solve for that then the only way to
manufacture is to manufacture in China
where they don't care about pollution so
what does Donald Trump do he he says we
got to get rid of these regulations on
the environment so that companies can
actually come back and start
manufacturing so that Americans can have
jobs so that Americans can send their
kids to good schools if you want to do
that these days can see how bad schools
are so that we can be energy independent
so that we can use our own resources we
have the entirety of Alaska they won't
go near we have a get we had a joke here
with Jack basobic and Daniel Turner
occupy Alaska invade Alaska it's it's
territory that we purchased from Russia
it's there it's open and it is massive
it is huge but for some reason we're
better off shutting down our own energy
production Outsourcing all of our jobs
to other countries and then getting
involved in Wars an attempt to justify
why we need the resources from them what
what's happened now with Ukraine and
Europe is that we're seeing 45 inflation
in Germany which is insane I think from
the last month year over year inflation
now it's this major spike they've been
they've made themselves dependent on
Russia and Donald Trump was like you
shouldn't do this instead of solving the
problems they just passed the buck until
it got too hot and now everything's
falling apart in their incompetent hands
was it like you shouldn't be relying on
Russia you should be reliant on us you
should be you should be paying your fair
share and figure out a way to I don't
know how about this don't shut down your
nuclear plants and he's like why are you
doing this start showing up your energy
needs you can't just sit here and let
Russia dictate how much you pay that was
the problem Russia through gas prom was
able to dictate massive prices so the US
was like instead of doing an event let's
just build pipelines down here through
Syria one of Russia's allies War emerges
from this the U.S in my opinion was very
happy to see the rise of Isis because it
was destabilizing Syria so instead of
actually dealing with the problem the
Democrat Administration was going oh
geez oh no these these terrorists
they're just growing Donald Trump gets
in Isis crushed Ukrainian conflict
dissipating Biden gets back in all of a
sudden Middle East destabilization Syria
is hot once again the fall of
Afghanistan and war in Ukraine these
people are Psychopathic morons and and
they think to go back to what you said
it was a good question if you you
thought a crazy person was was going to
take over do you think it's right to
hack an election or whatever these
Democrats think they're justified in
russiagate Ukraine gate and other
nonsense because Trump is is crazy but
the people supporting this are just
being treated like mushrooms kept in the
dark and fed crap by the corporate press
and by the politicians who just want
power and don't want to actually roll up
their sleeves and do hard work the
reality of the United States is that if
we brought the jobs back lives would get
so much better for the working class but
those powerful Elites they wouldn't be
able to exploit slave labor in foreign
countries so their net worths would go
down they don't like the idea of closing
the gap of wealth and equality in this
country they would rather own the
industry send the jobs to China pay a
buck an hour make tons of cash
extracting and exporting our jobs and
wealth to a foreign country meanwhile
the American people suffer for it and
then we get the opioid crisis and then
we get foreign war and then they expect
you to send your kids over there to die
so they can keep that system going
Donald Trump comes in and for all the
things wrong with the man that is worthy
of criticism he says hey okay let's not
do that and people are like okay a start
you know we had Dave Smith on the show
I'm a big fan he's an awesome guy and
someone commented and it was brilliant
they said Dave you know Dave says what
Trump did was still bad and that
shouldn't be the standard by which we we
vote and I agree but
someone commented this problem was
created over 100 years and it's going to
take a decent amount of time to solve we
can't just expect a 100 Year problem to
be erased and I think Donald Trump was
bringing a lot of solutions to Abraham
Accords no new Wars these things were
good bringing jobs back to America
bringing energy back to America making
this country about itself being like we
shouldn't be the World Police we
shouldn't be blowing up kids sending our
kids we should say we're going to clean
our own room we're going to make our
country better and we're going to
encourage a rising tide so that
everybody's ships will will rise instead
what we have is the Clinton Foundation
the liberal International economy or the
liberal world order as they call it
saying we should be in charge of
everyone because we are better men I
disagree thanks for checking out this
segment from the timcast IRL podcast but
if you want to check out the full show
live tune in Monday through Friday at 8
pm and if you want more special access
content head over to timcast.com and
become a member your member membership
helps sustain this company keep our
journalists employed makes this show
happen and you will get access to
exclusive members only segments of the
timcast IRL podcast and there's a
massive library to check out so again go
to timcast.com or tune in Monday through
Friday at 8pm and we'll see you all
there